[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bringing chris sims who knows a lot
about football though chris
how are you i'm doing good i i was
wondering i mean first off
you know fritzy texted me i think after
the first
weekend of football or basketball
telling me
i was in the lead and i was like oh
great wow i can't believe i was in the
lead
but all my final four teams were like
out of it already so i knew i was gonna
get killed there so
uh i i uh that was a good game to watch
last night i feel bad for
gonzaga you know you have a year like
that and then to lose that way where it
was never even close
i do feel for them but baylor clearly
better yeah you had virginia michigan
villanova and illinois as your final
four
oh man you went over four i went over
four i'll be back next year i'm gonna i
didn't watch
much college basketball this year so i
need to uh
pay attention a little bit more uh for
whatever reason i just didn't get into
it this year
all right let's grade what the jets did
uh by trading sam darnold to carolina
well i i mean listen i like it you know
one first thing off the bat dan i'm a
zack wilson fan i
i think it's special you know i think
that's ultimately what they're thinking
too
they're they're seeing or their opinions
line up with me to where
wait okay film was great oh wait now we
had
pro day whoa holy cow everything we saw
on film he can do
you know in the pro day setting so that
kind of like uh
you know solidifies that aspect of it
and of course i'm sure they got to meet
with them and talk to them a little bit
more to where they
they check off all the boxes so yeah
i love it it's joe douglas he's taking a
quarterback
to start his era and he's going to build
a team with a young nucleus around this
young quarterback
sam darnold's still really good uh i
still have faith in him
but yeah for me this was this was the
right decision for the jets because i
think zach wilson's kind of that aaron
rodgers patrick mahomes type talent
now steve young uh the hall of fame
quarterback was on kmbr in san francisco
and he said that
zach wilson his family wants to have him
go to the niners
uh could could you see zach wilson say
hey
i don't want to go to the jets here whoa
i mean that would be some
gutsy play it's the same offense either
way
i mean that we do know now of course hey
i i got respect for michael lafleur but
he's not kyle
shanahan kyle shanahan is arguably the
most creative offensive play caller in
football certainly
and everybody's top three or four that's
for sure
uh i you know john beck who coaches
zach wilson he of course played for kyle
shanahan
so i'm sure there's some things he's
heard but you know
again i i think that's dicey water would
i love that for my friend
and would i love to see zach wilson out
there in that offense with that football
team
sure of course i would uh but i i don't
know i don't know if this is zach
wilson's
that type of guy that's going to pull
this type of move off all right carolina
gets sam darnold
i i i think it's a perfect fit for
carolina
you know i think the first thing that
goes to my mind is
okay carolina didn't like what they
might get at number eight as far as
drafting a quarterback right
i think that's the first thing that kind
of went oh what's going to happen with
these five
first round quarterbacks now but then
when they just talk about sam darnold
and you know i know i've talked to you
about this a little bit he didn't have a
support system
carolina's gonna run that joe brady aka
sean payton offense that we saw they
want a joe burrow drew brees type of guy
not necessarily like the biggest arm
guys in the world but guys who
are smart can get the ball out of their
hand in a hurry
and phenomenal intermediate thrower
that's where i always look at sam
darnold and just evaluate him and go
great 12-yard throw ooh
great 15-yard in cut wow ooh 20-yard you
know skinny post
perfect all of that and i think that's
the way they want to run their offense
that way
let alone with the receivers they have
and robbie anderson and dj moore who's a
superstar and mccaffrey coming out and
all of that
i just think donald's a more talented
football player
and uh can deliver more for the offense
and talent they have there in carolina
i'm curious if and and i've said this
before reported this that there are four
different people have said that the
niners are taking
mack jones but i was told that there was
still some
questions about is trey lance make more
sense whether that's true or not
that's what i was told now you have
atlanta
at four what's atlanta doing
is it do they do they get matt ryan's
successor
or do they give him some ammo here to
make another run
i know well that's the million dollar
question and i think they are you know
again you you know my thoughts i think
the 49ers are going to go mac jones
all right i do i think that's also why
you see carolina
make this move because they were
probably hoping wait mac jones he could
be that joe burrow drew brees guys we
talked about
to run our offense so that's why they
moved on from that
but but atlanta is yeah one of the
mysteries i mean everybody in the nfl
thinks they're hot
on trey lance at number four it makes
sense as far as the situation's
concerned
you know yeah i think he's a guy that
needs to sit behind somebody for a year
uh you know and learn how to play and
polish and
and learn how to read defenses and go
through progressions
you don't see a ton of that life was
made very easy for him at north dakota
state
they ran the ball it was play actions it
was one or two guys and then he'd take
off and run
and do that so that from that standpoint
it makes sense
but i mean with the air the era we're in
right now
2021 what is matt ryan 36 years old i
can't remember exactly off the top of my
head
but he's got a lot of good years left
here to where i just don't know if i
would quite be thinking about making the
quarterback move yet
and i would think man ryan tannehill
plays similar
to ryan tannehill who arthur smith just
came from there
with the tennessee titans and i would
think that would be a perfect fit or a
perfect match together
yeah i'm just not sure if you you know
plug kyle pitts in there
uh i know that's what i i hear you
you're right
plug a kyle pits in there and that'll
change their
team when you talk about calvin ridley
julio jones and now
him at tight end and he's a a solid
blocker not a great blocker but willing
and going to do that you look at all
those things
and yeah they're going to have something
special there to deal with on that side
of the ball
but i'm also wondering you know you have
cincinnati at five
yeah and i don't know if is somebody
gonna trade up
you know is is somebody gonna trade up
to four with atlanta is somebody gonna
trade up to five you know is denver
going to do
anything here it feels like you know
that uh quarterback carousel
you know we got the game of musical
chairs and somebody's not going to have
a seat here
i i agree i think that's what's
interesting and i think what atlanta
you might hear at least from my
standpoint as we go
further here i think there there's also
the possibility they go
wait we don't if we want trey lance it
doesn't seem like we got to take them at
four maybe they could trade down
a little bit like that you know again
pick number four for a quarterback
who didn't play last year and then even
the year before that like we talked
about
the game was made simple and there's
very few drop back passes
man that would scare the hell out of me
dan there's just no way i'd pick a
quarterback
like that in the top five there's
absolutely no way um so
but i think to your point you know now
with the carolina seat filled
denver i i have a hard time thinking
they're gonna
draft a quarterback i could see them
maybe get in the teddy bridgewater
conversation or something like that
to compete with drew lock if drew lock
falls apart early in the season hey we
got teddy bridgewater
to fall back on i could certainly see
that but yo
after you get past that top 10 and those
teams we just mentioned
who else is there maybe new england at
15
maybe washington at 19 you know that
that's where it does get interesting and
it could be one of those things where a
few of these guys fall to later in the
first round
i would not be shocked by that i thought
new england might go up
right right but i think yes
i think that i think i had that same
thought that they might go up but my
thought was it would be to go up to get
mac jones
and now shanahan and the 49ers have
squashed that
so i'm sure that's changed their plans a
little bit too
and who knows you know again i think
helen mon from texas a m is a first
round quarterback
you know and maybe new england's got
their eye on him in the second round
trade up then do something like that
yeah uh there's still some guys out
there that got some talent
uh mclovin has a poll question for you
chris okay
which team had the best uh offseason in
the quarterback market so far
the rams getting matthew stafford the
panthers getting sam darnold
the jets trading sam darnold uh the
lion's getting jared goff the 49ers
trading up to three
or the bears getting andy dalton whoa
okay so we know it's not the bears okay
all right so we're going to really for
me
it comes down to the zack wilson jets
and the matthew stafford rams and i'm
gonna go with matthew stafford and the
rams right now
i am yeah i mean that was a big time
move by the los angeles rams to
to pull that off and stafford you know
as we all know
has some really really special abilities
about his game it's one of the greatest
arms ever
you know he's been in some crap crap
situations
so now to see him on that team with that
defense now mcvay can open up the
playbook a little bit
i think that's the one i'm most excited
about and of course he's a proven
commodity
not like these you know first-round
picks that we haven't seen play yet i
know what i'm getting at matthew
stafford
although he hasn't won a game in the
playoffs oh i know but
you know it's not he can't he can't
catch the ball or not call penalties
like he did in the dallas game or the
seattle playoff game
you know it wasn't his fault they didn't
win those games i think there is a
difference to that
yeah could you see a scenario where
aaron rodgers
hosts jeopardy and continues to play
quarterback for the packers
well i i i mean you're really
i would love to see it for theatrics i
mean you and i would have a lot of great
talks you know
lead after games during the week if that
was the case
but if you're gonna do that you better
be careful of how you orchestrate it
i mean you and i both know like if he
has a game where he throws three
interceptions and they lose by ten
points
and he was you know busy filming
jeopardy the monday before
i mean that's what we're going to roast
him on he's never going to hear the end
of that well he won't he won't film any
episodes during the season
so you think it'll be all off season
yeah yeah yeah yeah it can it can happen
yeah it could happen whatever yes all
right yes all right
yes i could see a scenario of that
happening i definitely can
you know the offseason the way it's set
up right now in the nfl
he can certainly pull that off work get
prepared for the green bay packers
take a day here and there to do jeopardy
is not going to ruin his preparation as
long as it's not during the season
i i kind of like it i want to see it
actually yeah he can make this happen
uh it's about 50 days but he's got to do
five
shows each day and then you meet that
number
and he'd be able to do it but i'm
there's something else going on in
greenback
i agree that's where i wanted to go with
that yeah i agree there's something
going on but the only way it changes
is if they trade jordan love as long as
jordan love is there then there's going
to be
you know friction something you know
that's underlying
and maybe it's not even that it's
percolating to the surface here
it it if you made me bet money i would
say this is aaron rodgers last year in
green bay
the the the it's over that he's going to
he's drawn a line in the sand
there's no clarity to his future and
he's going to draw a line
he didn't draw the line in the center i
know he didn't i think he's drawing
i think he's going to draw his own line
in the sand and be like okay
you want to do this and i see your line
over there i'm going to wipe it away and
draw my own line and
this is it we're done you know i i do i
have that sense too dan
you know i even brought up to florio
today about you know his restructuring
of his contract
and i just thought like you know what
maybe he would say no to some of those
things too just to be like no i'm not
helping you out sorry we're not going to
add years to my career
or add years to the contract or anything
like that i'm gonna make it to where i
can wiggle
and get the hell out of here if i want
at the end of this season
how did it work for the patriots when
they drew a line in the sand
well not so good not so good it's it's
there's some similarities here i think
you know i'm sure that's giving rogers a
little confidence to where he looks at
it and goes wait
wait they're not kind of you know
committing to me to the future
and they're not willing to kind of go
all in to help me which is some of the
brady issues with new england
and i'm out here at the end of my career
where i need somebody that's going to go
all in it's it's it's
my last push and no it didn't work out
very well for the new england patriots
and that's either but
at some point chris you have to utilize
jordan loves contract
like you have to go we drafted him you
don't want to get him into his
fourth year and then you go okay let's
see what you have and now we may have to
franchise you or give you that extension
it just doesn't that that doesn't make
practical sense for the past no
it's bad business that's why picking
them was bad business you know i mean
let's go to the one position on our team
that we know
is top-notch in the nfl and like
not even you can't even argue he's not a
top three at his position
let's draft the guy for the future there
i mean that's where it does not make
sense to me
at all it never will rogers was just too
good last year
like he was better than the packers
thought he was going to be in my opinion
i guess so i guess there's there's
something to that because they're like
oh my god
he won the mvp you know i know
there was signs the year before though
even though it wasn't perfect the year
before
there was still a lot of moments where
you went ooh he's getting comfortable in
this offense
this is starting to look like the old
aaron rodgers once again
and of course yeah you're right he's
they're on the same page with him and
lefleur everything's perfect
other than that he could use another
weapon to really kind of make that
offense elite elite
uh thanks for joining us as always hey
you the man keep your head up
yeah i will i will i'll go i'll keep
working on my ncaa bracket no problem
yeah
all right that's chris sims pro football
talk live co-host with mike florio